you
the Millers house at Valley Mill in the
Maryland countryside for 200 years as
long as we have been a nation people
have dwelt in this house farmed the
fields ground the grain lived and died
how did they live even in America where
nature is generous life is hard
the energy of back an aching muscle
plows the land splits the rails does the
work for more than a century working
energy is human and animal labor toiling
from dawn till dawn
from the beginning when even windmills
and waterwheels were few and far between
people have had to manage for themselves
life is good but even to the very end
hands are never aisle
it is still as God spoke to Adam by the
sweat of thy brow shalt thou eat bread
during the first century of settlement
towns and cities grow after London
Philadelphia is the largest city in the
British Empire
a center of trade in learning Quaker
restraint and George e'en elegance
when resentment against British rule
breaks out at rebellion America becomes
independent the war is long and bitterly
fought still in April 1775 the month of
Lexington readers of the Pennsylvania
magazine are learning of an ingenious
new horsepower dredge
short of working hands Americans are
interested in any inventions that
promise to save labor ships moved by
wind power or the only form of
communication the new States have with
Europe their main link with each other
with favoring winds ships often take
more than a month to cross the Atlantic
the fashionable event among
intellectuals is the electrical party
where you can receive a real electric
shock whilst touching or even kissing
someone else
Philadelphia's own dr. Franklin believes
electricity to be in the lightning bolt
itself however he sees little promise in
the new steam engines people are talking
about
a new homestead in the unsettled West
Country of Pennsylvania a family is
trying to clear the land and bring in a
crop before winter comes time is short
everybody works the fire is only serving
to rid the land of brush and he wonders
what is this force how could it be
captured how could it be used there is
work to be done he leaves it for wiser
heads to puzzle out why in a world
brimming with energy mankind is
sentenced to a lifetime at hard labor
the scientists of his day are beginning
to grasp the great interplay of forces
in nature from the Sun to the power
sleeping in wood and coal inventors are
busy
a native genius oliver evans designs a
new mill in which the great wooden wheel
powers of completely automatic operation
grains going in one end flour coming out
via inventors of the 19th century are
ingenious at finding new ways to use the
energy of falling water
but they're great achieve is using fire
to make steam generating undreamed of
mechanical energy early steam engines
give way to higher pressure models
strong steam they call
fired by wood or coal the engines
quickly prove their power to run
machines
when steam is made to turn wheels the
conquest of energy becomes the conquest
of distance
the steam engine grows paddles coal
burning steamers offer service that is
more dependable than safer at first
they're slower than the fast new sailing
Clippers but by 1840 steam ships have
crossed the Atlantic in 18 days labor
hungry farmers are cheering new
machinery the Reaper the binder the
cultivator in a hundred variations the
spreading network of rails starts some
forty niners west as far as the tracks
go but just over the western horizon is
a greater treasure harvests of grain
increased a thousandfold by the Reaper
and brought close to market by the
railroad by the 1870s America is a new
nation of big cities and growing
industries a country that has been torn
apart then reunited
in 1876 a special train takes passengers
from New York to San Francisco in just
83 hours and America has a birthday to
celebrate 100 years of Independence the
Centennial Exhibition at Philadelphia is
the biggest show this nation has ever
seen out of 40 million Americans 5
million will come to see it and there is
much to see but if the festival has one
theme it is power
the conquest of energy made possible by
iron steam and coal the main attraction
is a giant Corliss engine President
Grant and the Emperor of Brazil joined
to set the big machine in motion at last
inventors are making use of America's
vast store of natural resources
visitors remember the unfailing good
humor of the crowds that Centennial some
times are hard in 1876 but on this
occasion the humblest or the newest
American can take pride in his country
Memorial Hall still stands where grant
opened the Centennial a hundred years
ago
smiling Columbia still extends a welcome
to all of North and Sun
at dusk the great plaza still echoes to
the ban the voices the excitement of a
century past their buildings tell us of
these people that they were confident
they built massively boldly and well and
some of them glimpsed a future in which
man's new mastery of energy might lead
to an era of Plenty for all mankind
the Centennial heralds the future in
another way on the 4th of July 1876 as
Americans celebrate Independence Hall is
illuminated by a new form of energy
electric arcs light up the venerable
spine
many scientists are searching elsewhere
in nature John Ericsson looks to solar
energy he has made fundamental studies
constructed what he calls solar engines
sunlight falling on the rooftops of
Philadelphia he says would power 5,000
steam engines other engineers are
exploring different paths some are
trying to find a way to generate power
from you fuels that are available such
as petroleum and illuminating gas the
internal combustion engine is being
tinkered and hammered into existence
the great-grandfather of all the
automobile engines airplane motors and
power mowers is getting a trial run
- his practiced here it sounds good and
it looks good engineers are still
confronting basic questions with every
practical advance what happens when
energy changes from one form to another
what laws govern the transformation of
heat into power what is energy
questions the scientists of his day are
working to answer the electrical age is
doing a new kind of light the
incandescent lamp is one of the many
inventions Thomas Edison would give to
the world from generators electricity
can be sent as if by magic through
slender wires over long distances within
a few years in cities across the land
electricity transforms the dark night
for many Americans on the western
frontier life is as primitive as it was
a century before in new settlements they
stopped for a moment to have their
picture taken
sometimes they show us more than they
know life is hard in a new country
others seem more hopeful the nation is
growing and changing many new immigrants
come hands ready to work a million a
year the camera documents them and
Americans of this time who pause to look
at us from the midst of their lives
times are changing
the age of animal power is soon to pass
engines are moving themselves into the
fields
the first tractors some steam powered
some moved by new internal combustion
gasoline engines with the growing demand
for fuel petroleum production expands by
nineteen three offshore drilling has
been started not that there is any
shortage America's supply of oil seems
endless and soon every man's dream is to
own a shining new automobile the great
American Joyride has begun with
lightweight engines and powerful
gasoline fuel another long cherished
dream is beginning to come true
a new Edison invention is well underway
by 1900 farsighted producers have
discovered the formula for success a
sophisticated combination of sex and
violence motion pictures are also
documenting an incredible era of
industrial growth
the factory workforce totals many
millions men women and children coal has
long since replaced wood as the prime
energy source for industry making and
using energy is big business
giant generators are being built
electric motors of all sizes and
descriptions for industry and home use
street lighting subways and trolley
lines
the new century is picking up speed and
with it the pace of life quickens
the energy revolution has launched the
country on a voyage destination unknown
and people are rushing to get on
for many the new jobs means liberation
from the drudgery and loneliness of farm
life for many others it means only
repetitious routine work for better or
for worse
the machine has arrived and Americans
struggled to master it some succeed and
for some well the internal combustion
engine will always remain a mystery 4th
of July in a small western town time the
early twenties this year as every year
the firemen compete to prove that human
speed and agility have no equal but hose
pressure comes direct from a
hard-working pumping engine Americans
are learning to live with the Machine
trying to gain the benefits of progress
in health and comfort in a better life
while absorbing the shock of many
changes
the cameras of small town photographers
mirror these decades the 20s the 30s and
40s in the faces of ordinary people
while change continues to sweep across
their lives
today the world they have built
surrounds us based on 200 years of
invention science and human labour
energy powers a nation geared to using
it freely to live and move make and
produced
the hopes of the past for overflowing
abundance seemed realized and yet the
very control over nature our forefathers
worked so hard to achieve has led to a
crisis in our time different than any
they encountered the fuels they thought
inexhaustible or being used up rapidly
America is running out of gas and it is
our turn to seek new ways to generate
power each time we have shifted to new
sources of power history tells us it's
taken 60 years America cannot afford to
wait to promote a national effort a
federal agency has been created to plan
the best use of our present resources to
mobilize science industry and government
to develop new sources of energy and to
accomplish this without injuring the
environment it's an American tradition
confidence in man's powers of invention
every promising source is being explored
from machines that draw power out of the
free flowing tides of air and sunlight
diffusion our massive effort in the
complex field of nuclear reactions with
the promise of power that is truly
limitless
science has already harnessed the first
new source of power discovered in a
century nuclear reactors have been
generating electricity for more than 25
years by 1990 they will meet a large
part of our needs for power in the
nation's oil fields old wells are being
treated to make them give up more oil
enhanced recovery it's called and we are
going far to bring in new supplies
producing more energy would be
meaningless without conservation a major
study focuses on America's favorite
means of transportation searching for
engines that will go much farther on
much less fuel battery powered cars are
being tested and a variety of other
power plants to save energy the interest
future drivers show is more than curious
it's a look into the next 20 years
still another long-range effort
studies how to extract oil trapped in
layers of rock oil shale what
prospectors of the past thought
worthless is crushed and processed in a
pilot plant a small-scale trial of full
production that a 19th century
capitalist would have envied
what comes out is oil along with the
data on recovery that will guide further
development much work is concentrating
on the fuel that is still America's
primary resource our vast reserves of
coal coal we are learning is more than
coal a complex hydrocarbon whose
chemistry is not easily understood using
this knowledge in new plants our present
ability to transform coal into synthetic
gas or oil will be greatly expand
a research project in combustion mixes
high sulfur coal with limestone to make
it burn cleaner and more efficiently in
a pilot plant the mixture is consumed
under highly controlled conditions with
attention that a humble scuttle of coal
never enjoyed before
floating on a stream of air the
particles burn to power a million watt
gas turbine
it seems a setting for the 19th century
fantasy of a voyage to the center of the
earth in a western desert they're piping
high pressure steam and brine from far
below the surface to learn how it might
be harnessed to a turbine generator some
geothermal forces are already being used
to meet 1/3 of San Francisco's power
needs at other sites we are exploring
use of geothermal reservoirs that have
useful temperatures as low as 300
degrees Fahrenheit
some studies have a significance far
beyond their size in this miniature
experiment the scientist is burning coal
inside a glass column to determine if
coal might be burned while still in the
earth to generate methane gas
in his curiosity he is part of a
tradition of everyone who ever gazed in
wonder at fire and he too is asking
questions how best to turn this fuel
into useful energy how can we produce
energy without waste the dreams of
Erickson and other visionaries move a
step closer to achievement with renewed
studies of Sun up the ultimate goal to
turn the sun's energy directly into
electricity
Erikson's proposal to cover rooftops
with solar collectors has been put into
practice collectors soak up Sun to
provide buildings below with heat or
cooling and they send data to a battery
of recorders to help chart the way in
the use of solar energy
in a time of shortages we are still
surrounded by a world that is
overflowing with energy the forces still
hidden deep in the nucleus of the atom
or in the flame or the seas can become
ours just as others before us harnessed
elemental powers of heat and electricity
we who share in their achievements
cannot give any less imagination or
skill to the problems we face in our own
time to find sources of energy that are
truly inexhaustible in the Sun or in the
world around us
the people who crowd to see the place
where long ago thirteen United colonies
declared themselves free and independent
are not so different from the people who
waited one july day for the statehouse
bell to ring
you
there are many people in the procession
that moves out of the past into the
future the people who built the house at
Valley Mill who farmed its land and
ground its grain
the same people who's capable hands
forged the foundations of modern life
the people working today with all of
those from one generation to the next
who seek to lift out of bondage man's
body and his spirit
you